there are 60 000 new infections recorded
today partly driven by kids spreading
this new strain more readily
parents want realism can you look
parents in the eye and tell them that
all kids will definitely be back in the
classroom before the summer holidays
so patrick valance we've heard quite a
lot recently about a second new variant
this is the one from south africa
has it reached our shores and how
worried should we be about the south
african variant of coronavirus being
resistant to the vaccine
and professor chris witte how normal can
life really be
after just the 13.2 million most
vulnerable alone
have been vaccinated isn't the risk for
those age 20
up to 50 too high to let it rip through
those
age groups uh well sam i'll i'll take
the
the first one of those excellent uh
questions uh just on
uh whether we can be absolutely sure
that uh
that schools will uh will reopen well i
just go back to the answer really i gave
to
to robert peston we think
that with the vaccination program we can
do a huge amount to
uh take out of the path of the virus
those who are
most vulnerable that clearly offers
opportunities
to our country uh to to do things
differently
uh to approach the uh the whole issue of
non-pharmaceutical interventions
very differently so i'm you know i'm i'm
full of the
the same optimism uh and fundamental
hope about the
the position that uh that i think chris
has uh adopted
uh uh and that i think that things
really will be very different
uh by the spring and that is what i
would certainly say to every parent
in the land so on the question of the
variance
um as a virus replicates you get changes
in the genetic code as
new variant new mutations come in and
things change and
and those changes in the genetic code
then lead to changes sometimes in parts
of the protein
and that may lead to shape changes or
charge changes on the protein
that might mean that the virus becomes
recognized differently by the immune
system and that's really the
the concern that people are looking at
if i take the uk
variant um what we know is that those
changes and there was
22 changes in in in the genetic code
um made the virus more transmissible as
far as we can see it doesn't make it
hidden from the immune system so if
you've had an infection before
actually the evidence is you probably
neutralize
this virus as well and the expectation
is the same would be for a vaccine
with the south africa variant there's
another change
that change is theoretically a bit more
substantial in terms of the
shape if you like so it has a bit more
of an effect potentially on the shape of
the
of the um viral protein
which theoretically gives it a bit more
risk of not being recognized
but there's nothing again yet to suggest
that's the case so this is being looked
at
very actively and it's worth remembering
that when a when a
vaccine is given you don't just make one
antibody against one bit you make lots
of antibodies against lots of different
bits
and so it's very unlikely that all of
that would be escaped by any mutation
it's more likely
that if there's an effect it's a sort of
minor effect to decrease the
binding or decrease the efficacy of the
vaccine but we don't know yet for the
south africa and that needs to be looked
at
but it's a theoretical risk and every
time we see a variant that's going to be
the question that comes up but it needs
to be looked at but at the moment you'd
say that
the most likely thing is that this
wouldn't abolish vaccine effect it may
have some
um if uh overall effect on efficacy but
we don't know